well
say hi cristian cásseres with his brief
news now in spanish the
las vegas metropolitan police
arrested a driver accused of
hitting and killing a pedestrian east
of the valley this happened near wayne and
perez shortly after four thirty
on  At dawn the authorities said
that the driver of a Chevy truck
got on the sidewalk and ran over two
people. The second victim was not
injured. The officers located the
vehicle and managed to arrest the
driver. I tell you that three
weeks after firing the superintendent
of the  doctor jesus jara the board of directors
of the cork county school district
changed its mind in a vote of 4 to
3 the board of directors decided not to terminate
his contract now the question would be if
jara wanted to stay in the
school district after making this decision the
members of  the board of directors
put the election on an
interim intel superintendent on hold until
now and it's about  of the
end of year parties down sounds a morlan has already been
transformed into a winter wonderland
as of friday this
season begins with a festival at night
every friday and saturday at 6
pm until december 18 and we
close with a  look at the
temperatures we end the week with
temperatures reaching 72 degrees on the
weekend we will be in the high
60s and low 70s so
by thanksgiving as we can see we will
have a day almost in the 65s i
am cristian cásseres with your new
news now in spanish good
day